اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه المصلى
القبلي في المسجد الاقصى المبارك واخرجت
المعتكفين بالقوه وابعدتهم خارج اسوار
المسجد وذكرت دائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه في
القدس ان سلطات الاحتلال سمحت باقتحام
اكثر من 130 مستوطنا ساحات الاقصى حيث
ادوا طقوسا تلموديه قبل ان يغادروا فيما
ذكر شهود عيان ان السلطات الاحتلال نفذت
حمله اعتقالات وابعاد عن الاقصى في اجراء
استباقي عشيه عيد الفصح اليهودي الذي
يصادف الاربعاء المقبل
اصيب ثلاثه فلسطينيين بينهم امراه جراء
اعتداء جيش الاحتلال ومستوطنين عليهم
بالضرب في بلده سويف جنوب الضفه الغربيه
وقال ان مجموعات من مستوطن بيت عين
المحاذيه للبلدق تحمت اراضي لفلسطينيين
وهاجمت بحمايه من جيش الاحتلال رعاه اغنام
واعتدت عليهم بالضرب ما ادى الى وقوع
اصابات من جهتها كد الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني اصابه شاب بكسور جراء تعرضه
لعمليه دهس من مركبه عسكريه اسرائيليه قرب
بلده سورف